redux helps manage application states
and it is often used with react nicole
thidani is very experienced with redux
and he will take you from beginner to
advanced with redux hello everyone my
name is nikhil and in this video i will
be teaching you the redux and i will
take you from very beginner level to the
advanced level so first we will dive
into the basics of the redux and we will
build a counter application and then we
will move on to the bigger project where
we will create a shopping cart
application and the whole card data will
be then fetched via the firebase and
then we will manage the shopping cart
logic with the redux state management
tool which is a central data store and
then we will fetch all of the things
from the http request and then we will
try the thunk pattern as well
so let's start so now please like the
video if you are new to the channel and
please subscribe as well so that some
more people can see this video and i
will create more videos like this so now
let's dive into the basics of the redux
so right now about the redux so there
are some basic requirements for the
react redux application so you should
have the basic knowledge of how the
react works and now we will see about
some terminologies in the redux
so first redux so redux is a state
management tool which help us to manage
the complex states and with the help of
redux we can create a cds which is
exactly the central data store which
help us to manage the whole data store
in just one stone so the whole state can
be managed in just one data store
so about the reducers so about the
reducer functions they manages the state
and returns the newly updated state so
they are actually the function which
manages the states in the redux and
there are some actions which is a part
of the reducer function which is
actually the parameter in the reducer
function
so they have the two properties of type
and then it is a payload property so the
type property has a unique identifier in
it and the payload property has the data
in it and about the dispatch so the
dispatch is created whenever we want to
send an event data so whenever an event
occurs whenever we want to send the data
to the redux so we have to use the
dispatch function to send the actions to
update the data so these are about the
basic terminologies in the redux so now
we will create the redact redux
application to build the sound
application in the project
so i have created a basic react
application here and you should also
create it from the command npx create
iphone react
iphone app and then the app name i have
given the app name as the react redux so
you can also give any name to this and
then we need to go inside the directory
and then we need to install two
libraries of the redux which is the npm
install
and the first library is the redux
itself and then there is
also a library with the react it will
the react hyphen redux so we have to
install these two also
so we have to wait till it completes the
installation in that
and now package is uninstalled so now we
have to go to inside the reacted
application from here also
and now we need to create this store
inside the source folder so the store
will contain all the state management
tools so we have to create a new folder
it will the store
and then we have to create an index.js
file in the store index.js
and now we have to handle all of the
react states in just single index.js
file so now first we have to import the
redux so it will be the import
and then the function will be the create
store
from the redux
and then we need to create here the
store
so the cons
store will be equals to the create store
but now the create store needs a reducer
so we have to create a reducer function
also as we have talked in the ppt
so it will be the const reducer
function
will be equals to a an arrow function
and this will contain a state
and action as the parameters so the
state is a state which we will provide
and the action the action will have two
properties in that the first is the type
and the payload which we have discussed
in the ppt so now in the reducer
function if i will not define nothing
here and then if i will not define the
create store
as the reducer function in that so now
the store is now created and then we can
use the store
so now for the state now if i will give
an initial value to the state as an
object so it will contain a counter and
the value will be the zero so now this
state has a counter property with the
zero value inside that so now we have to
handle the state here so so now if i
will now create a counter in the app.js
file and for the and for using the store
we need to go to the index.here which is
the root file and then we need to
provide a this store so we have to
provide the store to the whole
application which contains in the
application
so the app component will be the main
application component and it will
contain the store so all of the
components will have access to the react
store which is this index.js file so we
have to provide that now in the index.js
so we need to import here the import
it will be the provider
from the react redux
so the provider will provide a store and
then we can wrap our whole app component
of the react with the provider
so the provider will be now from the
react until the stick mode ends
so there will be the provider and now
the provider will contain a prop which
is the store and then the store we need
to provide the store which is in the
which we have to export the store so
then we have to export here the store
also export default store from here
and now we need to import the store in
the index.js so it will store so it will
be imported from the store application
from this index.js and now we have given
this store so now the app component have
access to the store and now we need to
handle the state and then we need to
show the state so in the app.js if i
will now go here
if i have to remove from the header till
the header
and then i will remove the class name
app also from here
and now we have to add here the h1 tag
which is a counter
app
and then
we can now provide here the counter
inside this
and then to get the counter here from
the index.js store now we need to get
here in the app.js with the use selector
hook and the use selector hook is
available in the react redux so we need
to import the use selector if i have to
remove the logo so import
the use selector
from the
react and the redux and then the use
selector will give us and help which we
can extract the counter from this
index.js store so it will be you
selector from the const
selector or like the counter
will be equals to the use selector
and then the used collector will be the
key
to get the counter and now the counter
will be done from the u selector so we
need to provide here the callback
function and the callback function will
have the state inside it and then we
have the counter property in the state
so we have to access the state dot
counter
so it will be the counter now so the
counter is now actually the counter so
if i will provide another
like h2 and inside that if i will
provide a counter here so to the counter
so now if i will now save and if i will
now just start the application now npm
start
so now we will see the counter on the
screen
so we have to wait till it compiles and
it loads to the browser
so now in the browser now so we have the
blank application so if i will now check
the error in the console that what
exactly is the error so the error is
because cannot raise property of the
undefined reading counter so now this
error is coming because now in the
index.js now we have a store and in the
app.js we are now accessing the counter
but in the reducer function we haven't
returned anything from the reducer
function so if i will now just return
here the counter or like return near the
main state which we have the state
inside that so if i will now save and if
i will now go again so now you will see
the counter app and the counter is now
showing on the screen so now if i will
now give a value of the 10 to the
counter so the 10 will be here
so then you will see we have the state
of the 10 here now we will create here
some reducer functions inside that so
now
i will move on to the app.js and inside
the counter i will create two buttons
button the on click will be equals to
the like increment
and then the
button will be the increment same and
then there will be another
so it will be having the on click
it will be the decrement
so now this will have the text of the
decrement
and then we need to create the functions
also with the const
increment
will be equals to a function
and same the cons decrement
will be equals to another function
inside that so now we have now the
increment and the decrements here so if
i will now save so now you will see two
buttons will be here of the increment
and the decrement
so now
i want this application to be when i
will click the increment so the counter
will increase and when i will click the
decrement the counter should decrease so
for this help now we need to dispatch an
action and now we have seen in the ppt
that how to that what exactly is the
dispatch so dispatch is used whenever we
want to send the data to the redux store
so for the dispatch we need to import
something from the react redux it will
use dispatch so the use dispatch
function will help us to dispatch an
action and then we have to provide a
unique action and then the redux store
will fetch the action and then it will
update the store
so for that in the app.js
for the increment now if i will now use
here the dispatch and for using the
dispatch first we have to give a
variable that the cons dispatch
will be equals to the use dispatch so
now we are now giving the reference of
the use dispatch to dispatch so it will
be here so it will be down dispatch and
then in the dispatch we have to provide
an action so for the action if i if i
will now provide an object
for the action so first it will contain
a type property so the type if i will
provide as the inc
increment and then if i will now save
and then we need to go to the index.js
store and now we have to check if we
have the action of the type with the inc
so we have to increment the counter so
now there are some limitations for the
react reducer function so first they
should be the synchronous function
and then
and the second limitation is that
we should
not mutate
the original state
so here we have two limitations that
first it should always be a synchronous
function and it should not contain an
async code inside that and we should not
mutate the original state and we are not
allowed to do that in the redux store
because it will crash the application
so it should always be a copy of the
original state and the main state should
not be updated so for that
i have to create the so if i will now
use here the if conditions so the if the
type equals to the if the action
dot type property which we are now
sending then
if the action dot type will be equals to
the increment inc
so then we need to create
here the new state and then we need to
return the state will be the return
it will be like an object with the state
property and the state will equals to
the counter
state will be equals to the state dot
counter which we have here and it will
be plus plus
so then we need to return near the state
object which will be equals to the state
dot counter plus plus so now if i will
use the counter as the zero start from
the zero
and then if i will now save so then you
will see if i will click on the
increment
so actually there is an error i think so
we have to fix that
so the error is coming because we are
now sending the state and now we are now
using the counter property so we have to
send here the counter so instead of the
state we need to stand here the counter
so if i will now save again and if i
will now click on the increment i think
the counter plus plus is not here so if
i will now add here this as a counter
plus one
and then you will see
it will increment the state so then you
will see the counter will increment now
the state so these are about handling
the state in that so here we are now
sending a dispatch action and action is
the inc and here we are fetching the
same action here inc if the action.type
equals to the inc so we have to return
the counter state and the counselor tab
will be the state dot counter plus one
so these are handling the states in the
redux and now if i will now use here the
decrement state and for the decrement we
need to send another dispatch so with
the dispatch and then the action type
will be equals to now the decrement so
it will go dec
so then we need to handle the dec in
that so we have to create one more if
statement if action
dot type property will be equal to the
decrement
so then we have to copy we have to
return the copied state counter
will be equals to the state dot counter
minus 1
so if i will now save again
so then you will see it so it will be
incremented and once i will create
decrement so it will be decremented the
original state so these are about
handling the counter app in the react
and the redux and now if we have to send
there some data to that if i will now
add here one more thing like in the
app.js if i will now add here another
button inside that
button and the button will be the add
and it will be the value
and the add value if it will be the 10
like it will be the on click
like it will be the add buy
so we have to create another function as
the add by
const and by
use to the an arrow function
and this will contain
a dispatch action and the dispatch
section will be equals to the type
property
and the type property will be equals to
the like the
add
and then if i will now provide you the
payload also so the action is an object
with the type and the payload property
so if i would provide here the payload
so it will be like the 10
and then you will see
so it will be the add by
10
so if i will now save and if i will now
move on to the so it will be in the
payload
payload will be equals to the 10
so now we need to go to the index.js
store so it will be the if now the
action
dot type
will be equals to the add
so then we need to return here the
copied state again so it will be equal
to the counter
will be equals to the state
dot counter
it will be plus and now we have the
action property and now we have the
payload property also in the action so
it will be the action
dot payload so if i will now save this
action.pillow so if i will now save this
and if i will now move on to the
application now
so once if i will now click at the
increment so increment is working
agreement is working so if i will click
add by 10 so then you will see 8 by 10
is also working so now we are sending
the data from the main app.js to the
redux store
so this is about the basic application
with the react and redux
so now we have created the application
and now there is one more way to do the
redux part and which is the redux
toolkit so if i will now move on to the
google chrome
now if i will now search for the redux
toolkit
do the redux toolkit
so then you will see which will help us
to manage the complex state and with the
batteries included like it will have the
functions in that which will help to
mutate the state and then which will
help us to manage the automatically
created the actions identifier so we
don't need to send the actions like the
hard-coded actions we are not providing
from the like the decrement the add the
increment and then the z text tool will
handle all the reducer functions inside
that and and we can create the reducer
functions here and then we can directly
call the reducer functions from the main
applications now if we have to use the
redux toolkit then we need to click on
the get started here and then if you
will click on the documentation so then
you will see first it will be the npx
create react app so it will directly
install the redux toolkit in that and if
we are using an existing app then we can
use the npm install redux js toolkit and
then what is included here so first it
will be the configure store which will
wrap the create store to provide the
simplified configuration options
and the create reducers action slices
and about the slices it accepts an
object of the reducer functions and then
we can call directly these objects from
the main applications like from the
app.js or anything it contains a slice
name and an initial state value and it
automatically generates the slice
reducer which corresponding action
creators so these are known as the
action creators so they automatically
get an action identifiers and then pass
to the reducer functions
so this will help us to do the all of
the things very easily and then it has a
big advantage that here we can mutate
the state
so we should not mutate the state
anyways but it will help us because the
redux toolkit uses a new package which
is immer which will help us to mutate
the state and then it automatically
identifies that which state has been
changed and then it will send an
automatically created copy of the state
to the main applications so it will help
us to mutate this so now we need to use
this application with that so first if i
will now move on to the main application
here if i will now close the server and
then we need to install this redux
toolkit so it will be the npm install
detox toolkit
so we have to click this and then we
have to paste this here so now you will
see it will be installed in a moment and
now the redux toolkit is now installed
and now we can just remove all of the
things from the index.js now from this
and now we have to build from the
scratch so it will be the first the
import we have to import the configure
store
gui store
from it will be from the redux toolkit
so at the rate redux toolkit redux
toolkit and then we need to now
configure the store and then we have to
import a create slice from there
and this will be the slice so it will be
imported and now we have to create a
slice so first it will be the const
counter slice
which will be equals to the create slice
function and then it will contain an
options with that so first it will
contain the name of the slice so the
name of the slice here will be the
counter
and then it will contain the initial
state and initial state will be equals
to like the counter
will be equals to like zero
and then it will contain the reducers
and the reducers will be an object which
will contain the functions so first
function which we have is the increment
so it will be the function there and
then it will the decrement
so it will also be the function and then
it will be the add
by
so it will also be the function
and they are exactly the reducer
functions so they will contain the state
and the actions inside that state and
the action
here also state
and the action
and here also the state
and action so first it will be in the
increments so then we can return here
this like
or we can directly return here the
mutated state so we can directly mutate
the state here into the state
dot counter it will be the plus one
so we have to do this and now same for
the decrement state dot counter will be
equals to the minus one
or like directly
doing this and then we can create here
the add by so it will be the state
dot counter
will be plus 10
so it will be equals to the plus 10 so
if i will now save and then we need to
create a configure store with that so it
will the const store
will be equals to the configure store
which we will do this and then it will
contain so first we have to provide an
object and it will contain a property of
the reducer and then we can provide a
directly the counter reducer like it
will be the counter slice dot reducer so
if i will now save we have to just
export the counter slice action so it
will be the export it will be the const
actions
will be equal to the counter slice dot
actions so now the actions which we are
writing here will be now exported and
then it will be imported in the main
app.js file so if i will now save and if
i will now move on to the index.js
the main.jsoi so it will be the like
import first we need to import here the
actions
should be the actions
from the store
from it will be like the from the
store
and the actions index so now the actions
will be now imported and now we have to
just accept the
instead of this decrement the type
so now the hard-coded values will not be
here so we can now just directly call
the actions dot increment so the
increment will be called whenever we
click on the increment and same for the
decrement so here it will be actions
dot decrement so here the decrement will
be called and here the same thing which
will provide we can call here the add by
actions
dot add buy and then we can provide here
any value as we can provide here the
payload to this property and action will
automatically be created from that so it
will be the 10 and then if i will now
save and if i will now just restart the
application and pm start so the
application will be now started
so now there is one error that module
bill failed because of uh because we are
not providing an equals to side the
object we have to give here the uh
colon so it will be an initial state and
the counter will be equal to zero so if
i will now save
and i should see if there are more
errors so there are more errors as the
export default imported as store was not
found in that
so first we need to get here like the
actions will be there and the stores so
we have now to export the default store
also export default and will the store
so if i will now save again so i should
see
it should be the compiled
so there is an another error so we have
to get this like expected an assignment
call of the function so an expression
index.js store here we don't have to
just to give a hard-coded value so if i
will provide a plus plus and here also
plus plus
and here
so
here it will be the minus minus
and here if i will now provide a
straight dot counter plus equals to it
will be the
plus action
action so it will be the payload so if i
will now say that that so then i think
there is a one more error expected as
simon starts over inspection so there
should also be anything like that
plus equals two will be that so if i
will now save again so now you will see
it is now compiled because it doesn't
need any hard coded value so if i will
now save and if i will now go to that
so now you will see it will contain the
same application so if i will now click
on the increment so then you will see
increment is done decrement is creating
so if i will click on the add by 10 so
then you will see the add by 10 is also
working and if i will now provide the
dynamic value of the app like the 20 so
then you will see it will be increased
by the 20. so if i will refresh at by 10
so it will be increases by the 20. so
this is the basic react application with
the redux functionalities and it
contains all the functionalities of the
redux and all the fundamental concepts
of the redux which are most important if
you are building a real world
application
so now we have built the basic counter
application with using the redux and the
redux js toolkit and now we will move
ahead with the larger application
i have created a basic structure of this
application which you can download or
clone this repository using the git and
then you can run the npm install command
to install the node modules and this
will be the application which will be
building so first it will be having a
login screen and then if i will now
click on the login button so the state
will be updated into the redux and then
the shopping cart application will be
shown and i am handling the card state
into the redux
stores and then i'm sending the data to
the backend to the firebase and then we
will handle the http states via the
notification as well like sending the
card data so if i will click on the add
to cart now you will see now we have a
notification of the request and
successfully and once i will click on
this again so then you will see requests
sent successfully again
and even if there is an error so
everything will be shown into the
notification as well and for these
products and i am using a dummy products
array to be displayed onto the screen
and the whole state of the application
including the cart items the total price
and the login logout screen is handled
with the redux dynamically and with
fetched with the firebase so isn't it
interesting so let's dive into this
project
and now i have a sample static project
for this application and we need to get
this application by going to the github
so we have a redux demo here and then we
need to select the branch so branch will
be the starting app for the starting
project so we have here the branch and
then we have to copy this url from there
so we have to copy this url from the
code and then we have to clone this
project here so we need to create a new
folder here as the shopping app
so it will not be inside the my app so
it will be in the shopping app
and then we need to go inside the
shopping cart from the command prompt so
here and then we can go inside it and
then we can run the command as a git
clone and then the url so once it will
be completed it will be cloned into the
shopping app so now you will see it is
now cloned and now we need to go inside
this application the redux demo and then
we need to go to the branch of the
starting app so it will be the git
checkout
and it will be the branch name so the
branch name will be the starting app
and then you will see it will be
switched to the starting app branch and
then you will see we have here the
source and then we have some components
as the auth and then we have a cart
component we have the cart item we have
the header we have the layout we have
the product and then we have here the
store application also and then we have
the app.js so then we need to just clear
the console
clear the command prompt and then we
need to run the npm install command to
install all of the dependencies
and now we can run the npm start command
to start the application so the
application will be started in a moment
so the application is now started and
now once we will go to the chrome so
then you will see there will be a login
screen on the chrome and once you will
click on the login and then nothing
happens and once you will go to the
app.js and then you will see we have
here the layout which is now commented
and once i will comment the auth
component and if i will just uncomment
the layout so then you will see we have
here the layout onto the screen
so we have here the redux shopping app
we have here some products on the screen
and then we have the cart and then we
have the total so these are the static
values but now we need to create a
dynamic and now this will be handled in
the redux store which is the central
data store
so we need to fix all of these
functionalities then so first we will
work on the auth component
so then when the user will be logged in
and then we need to show user the cart
and the shopping list so now we need to
work on the auth component first
so we can create here the central data
store by going to the store and then by
creating a new file as the auth
slice dot js so it will be the new slice
for the redux so then i will just uh
minimize this terminal i will just
minimize the file step from there also
so now we can build the functionality of
the auth slice so after creating the op
slice now we can just create a slice for
the auth so it will be the import and as
we create slice
and it will be imported from the redux
toolkit and then we need to just create
the slice so it will be the const as the
auth slice
and it will be equals to the create
slice function and then it will contain
an object with all of the
functionalities so first first property
will be equals to the name
so the name of this slice will be the
auth so we can define it as the auth and
the second field will be the initial
state so initial state will be equals to
now it will be a state now we can have a
state as the is logged in
to check the user if the user is logged
in or not and then we can just define
here some reducers so now reducer will
contain some functions inside that the
first function will be the login
so it is now the login function and then
there will be the logout function
so now we have the two functions in the
reducers and now we have to build the
functionality so login will contain the
state
and then the logout will also contain
the state as the parameter and now here
we are allowed to meet the state because
we are using the redux js toolkit and
not the redux or the react redux so you
should not always mutate the state but
now this library uses the immer package
to just mutate and creates a new copy
so we can here mutate the state so it
will be state
dot is logged in will be equals to the
true here
so this is now mutating of the state and
now in the log out we can just mutate
the state at the state dot is logged in
equals to the false so now we have the
two functions in the auth slice and now
we need to just export the slice so
first we need to export as the const
auth actions
so the actions will be exported as the
auth slice we have here and dot actions
so all of the actions of the observation
will be now exported so with the export
as the named export and then we need to
just export default
as the off slice so that it can be
imported in this store which will be the
main store in the index.js but for the
default
and then it will do the off slice
now we need to import it in the index.js
which will be the main store
of the redux so first we will import the
configure store
from the redux.js toolkit and then we
need to just build here the store so it
will the cons store
will be equals to here the configure
store
and the configure store will have an
object inside it at the reducers so the
reducer will contain an object this time
so it will be having first the auth
reducer and the auth reducer will
contain the auth slice and the auth
slice will be then imported from the
oscillise that we have exported as a
default so the auth slice dot reducer
so this is now exported as the reducer
of the auth and then we can just add
here for the shopping cart also but now
let's do it for the auth only so now we
can just export it as the default of the
store as the export default and it will
be the store
so now if i will now save so now you
will see all of the functionalities of
the auth component of the auth state is
now completed and now we need to go to
the index.js
which is the main file which is a root
application
so here we can just import
the
provider
and it will be imported from
the react redux
and then we can just wrap the app
component with the provider
so we can wrap the app component with
the provider by providing here the state
as the provider first it will be the
prop so prop will be equals to the store
and now we need to import the store from
the store of the redux store so it will
be the provider now so now you can see
the store is now imported and now we can
just grab here the app component and
then we can just close this so now you
will see all of these redux state store
will now be covered into the app
functionality into the app component
which is the main component in which all
of the files will be rendered all of the
components will be rendered so now you
can see here we have an error so the is
logged in is not defined in the odd
slice.js so we have to go and then we
have to go to the odd slice so then you
will see that is logged in here so we
haven't defined the is logged in because
we haven't defined at the value so this
logged in value will be equals to as the
false so if i will now save so now you
will see there should not be any error
so now it is compiled and now we need to
go to the app.js which is the main
component and then we need to grab the
state from the store so it will the cons
we need to grab the state from the u
selected hook as we did in the
introduction project that will be the
state name which is the is logged in
and it will be equals to the use
selector hook and the use selector hook
will be then imported from the redux
that will contain the state as the
callback parameter and then we need to
grab the state
the redux state of the auth
and the state name will be the is logged
in
so we need to grab the is logged in
state so this is the state from the
redux and then this is the name of the
state as we have exported in the store
here as the auth and then we need to
grab the state name which is the is
logged in
and then if i will now just console.log
the value of the is logged in
so now we should see the change on to
the screen so if i will now go to the
inspect
into the chrome
and then we should see the value here as
the false because now we have the state
of the false and once i will change the
state of it if i will now go to the op
slice once i will change the state as it
true so then you will see the state will
be shown as the true here now we can
create here the functionality that if
the user is logged in then we need to
show the user the shopping list so for
that once we will go to the app.js and
then we will see in the layout so then
we can just wrap here the auth component
into the expression and then we can
check if the user is not logged in if
the logged in is logged in is false then
we have to render the auth component and
if the user is logged in then we need to
show the user the layout so if it is
logged in and then we can show the user
as the layout so the layout will be
there as the component and if i will now
say because so now the logged in is true
so then it should show us the layout
onto the screen so now you will see it
is showing us the layout onto the screen
which is a static layout and then if the
user is not logged in so if i will now
go to the
auth slice so if the user is the false
so the login scene will be shown to the
screen
so then we can just
give the value as default share as the
default so we can go now to the auth
component from there so it will be the
auth and then we can change the content
by dynamically updating it so once the
form will be submitted so then we can
just
uh
create the is logged in as the true so
we can just add here the on submit prop
to the form so the on submit
and then it will be handled at the end
submit
and the handle submit will have a
function here const handle submit
will be equals to the function which
will contain the e as a parameter and
then it will be the e dot prevent
default
so the e dot prevent default will
prevent the browser from sending the
data from the form and it will just
prevent the page from the refreshing
also so even dot prevent default and
here we can dispatch the actions so for
the dispatching of the actions we need
to create the use dispatch hook so we
need to create a dispatch so the
dispatch will be equals to the use
dispatch and the use dispatch will be
then imported from the react redux so it
will contain a dispatch functionality
and then we need to dispatch some
actions go to the dispatch and then to
dispatch some actions we can import the
authorized actions which we have
exported into the auth slice so we can
get this so it will be the auth action
so it will be then imported from the op
slice and then
actions dot the login functionality so
once the user will click on the button
of the login so it will be logged in and
then the layout screen will be shown to
the user so now if i will now just save
and if i will not just refresh the page
once again so now you will see once the
user will click the login so now you
will see layout screen will be shown and
it contains a shopping list so now we
have created the auth slice component if
i would now refresh the page so then you
will see the shopping list will be gone
and now the user is not false is logged
in is now false and once i will click on
the login again so then you will see
user is logged in so now we can see here
the functionality but so here we haven't
sent any data to the form because now
this project is only structured to make
use of the central data store and it
will only handle the login state of the
user because this state will not be
handled by the redux so the only the
login state will be handled so we cannot
send any data to the firm or we can send
also but it will not impact the state so
we have to just work on the login
functionality
so now you can see we are now logged
into the shopping gap and now we have to
work and then we need to just fix this
static data here so once i will click on
the add to cart so the card should be
updated we can also increment or
decrement the card items from that so we
have the static products here so the
card functionality will be built then we
can create a store for the cart so it
will be the card slice so we can create
a new slice as the card slice
so with the card
slice
dot js so then we can just import here
the create slice from the react redux so
it will the create
slice
and then we can just create the slice
for the cart as the const card slice
and it will be equals to the create
style and then we can just add here as
the object so first it will contain the
name as always so the name will be
containing as a cart and then the second
it will contain the initial state so
here the initial state would be
different so the initial state will
contain first the items of the card so
with the items list
and then it will be an array
and then we can just have here the total
quantity
and then it will be having my default
value of the zero and then we can have a
show card
and it will be equals to the by default
as the false
so once i will click on the card so then
the card should be shown so we have to
handle that state also and now we can
just create the reducers functions so
this will be a complex logic here so
first the reducer function will be
containing the add to cart so once i
will click on the add to cart to any
product so the card should be updated so
it will be the new function here at the
add
to
cart
and then it will be the function
and then there will be also a function
for the remove to the cart
remove
from cart
and then it will also be the function
and then we can just create a one more
function to just
create as the set
show cart
and then it will be the function again
and then it will contain the state
so we can implement the set show card
first so it will contain a state and
then we can just add here as the state
dot show card will be equals to the true
now so and then we can just work on the
add to cart so now the add to card will
contain the state
and the action as the parameters inside
that so for the action we can get the
data from the user so once i will click
on the add to cart so this product will
be now sent to this reducer function and
then it will update so now the product
will be sent to the add to cart function
and now we need to just create a new
item so with the const as the new item
a new item will be equals to the action
dot payload which we will receive from
the add to cart functionality so the new
item is there and then we need to check
if the item is already there so we can
just increase the quantity of that item
so it will be there to check if the item
is already
available
so for this we need to create a const at
the existing item
and it will be equals to like the state
dot items
list
that we have so the state dot item list
and then we can just call here the find
function to find if it has any product
for the given condition so we have to
get this item so first it will the item
as the parameter and then we can just
fetch here like if the item which we
have
if its id is now equals
to the new item dot id
so then we can just fetch that existing
product will be there and now if the
existing product is there so i will just
uh
so if the existing product is now there
so then we can just create here some
functionalities like that
so if the existing item is available so
we can just increase the quantity like
the existing item
that we have dot quantity
will be
incremented as the quantity plus plus
and then we can just increase the price
also like the existing item dot price
will be incremented as the plus equals
to the new item
dot price so now we are now incrementing
the quantity and the price will be uh
which will be equals to the old price of
the existing item and the new price
which we are getting and it will be the
same as always from there so it will be
equals to that and then in the else case
where the product is not available
inside that so we can just create the
product so the else case will be there
and then we can just add here some
functionality to it so then we can just
add the product to the list so it will
be the state
dot items
list dot push so we can just push a
product and then it will be having an
object with the id
and the id will be equals to the new
item that we have grabbed dot id
and then it will be having the price
which will be equals to the new item
dot price which we will get from the
components and then it will contain a
quantity and it will be equals to the
one because if the quantity will be
equal to v2 then we have to go to the
existing item state and then we can just
go and then we can just grab it as the
total price the total price will be
equals to the new item
dot price
and then we can just have here the name
of the product also so the name will be
equals to the new item
dot name so these fields will be now
available into a single product so it
will contain id the price the quantity
and the total price will be equal to the
new item.price
and then we can just have here all of
the things is the same so now we have
created the add to cart functionality
and now we need to check if the add to
cart is working or not
so we can just go and then we can just
here just export the cart as the export
cons
it will be the cart actions
and it will be equals to the cart slice
dot actions
and then we can just uh export the card
slice export default as the card slice
and now we need to use this card slice
into the index.js store so it will be
there will be the another reducer as the
card so the card will be having a card
slice
dot it will be having the reducer of the
card slice so now we have the two
functions in the reducer which contains
the authentic cart and the auth contains
the reducer of the auth so now the add
to cart functionality is now completed
and now we need to go to the product dot
js which we have here which is
containing a single product inside that
and it contains the name id image url
and the price
so then we can just grab here the
add to cart function from there so we
have here the add to cart function so we
can just add the other on click to it
so the own click will be having a
function as the add to cart so then we
can create a the function also inside
that
on to card will be equals to the
function and then it will just dispatch
some actions so we need to get the
dispatch also as the cons dispatch
which will be equals
to the use dispatch so the use dispatch
will be then imported from the react
redux and then we can just call here the
dispatch
and then the dispatch will be having the
card actions
which will be imported from the card
slice and dot add to cart and then the
add to card will be having a payloads so
to send the payload we can send here the
object to it which will contain the name
of the product
and then it will contain the id of the
product and then it will contain the
price of the product so it will hang a
name id and the price so now we are not
adding as the name key equals to the
name because now this is the
functionality in the es6 so it will be
gone so the name id and price will be
sent to the add to cart function from
the store and then into the add to cart
function now we have the id name and the
price and the quantity and the total
price we are now handling the state only
from the redux store and not from the
component store so this will be handled
from there so once i will click on the
add to cart so the cart item should be
populated and now we can get the cart
items here also but for the just time
being so we can just add here the cons
as the cart items
will be equals to the use selector and
then the you selected will be imported
and then we can just grab here this
state and then we can just grab here the
state dot cart
dot items list
so the items list will be then there so
if i will now just console.log the item
list here also so we can check if we
have the cart items here so once i will
click on the add to cart so the add to
cart items will be then shown to the
cart so we have to go to the inspect
then consoles so we can just so now we
can see we have here the array of five
items so once i will click on the add to
cart so then you will see now we have
here the add to cart function on that so
then you will see we have the price
we have here the single array onto that
and it is rendering five times because
we have the five products on to that so
we have to get this functionality i will
remove this functionality from here and
then we can just have the functionality
in the main app component
so if i will now save and if i will now
just go to the chrome once again if i
will now clear the console so once i
will click on the add to cart so now you
will see we have a single product in the
array which will contain a macbook and
the price will be equals to like the 50
and the quantity will be close to the
two because now we have the two quantity
over here so if i will just refresh and
if i will just log in here so then you
will see once i will click on the add to
cart so then you will see we will have
here the id as the one we have here the
macbook which is containing the price as
the 25 and the quantity will be equals
to the one and the total price of this
macbook pro will be equals to the 25 and
once i will click on the add to cart
again so then you will see no new
product will be added to the array but
only the quantity will be increased and
the total price and the price will be
increased so now you will see the price
is now increased as the 50 and the
quantity will be equals to the
two so now we have here the
functionality of this so now we have to
see if we can do for the all of the
items so if i will now click on the add
to cart for the lenovo yoga once again
so now you will see we have the array of
the two items into the list so it will
contain the array and then you can see
the anova yoga is also there into this
and the price it equals to the 25 and
the quantity is one so if i will now
click on again on to this so then you
will see the quantity is now incremented
too
so i have now discovered an error so if
i will now click on the add to cart so
now you will see we have the array of
the product and once i will click again
to the same product so then you will see
now we can see here now we have the
price equals to the 75 but the total 5
is equals to the 25 so now it is just
opposite of it because the price should
be the 25 because this contains the
price of the 25
so the price should be the 25 and the
total fry should be containing the total
price into quantity which is the 75
so we need to go to the card slice
instead of this price we need to just
increase the total price
to the new item.price so if i will now
save so now you will see once i will
click on the login and once i will click
on the add to cart to the one product so
then you will see the price equals to
the 25
the quantity is equals to the one and
the total price 25 once i will click
again so now you will see the price will
be just
the 25 save and the total price will be
the 50. so now we have fixed this error
now we need to see the items on to the
cart so now we need to fix this items
because this is the static items on to
the card.js so if i will now go to the
card.js
now you will see we have the static item
so the quantity will be close to the
five so we need to see how many items we
have in the cart as we seen in the array
list
so then we need to go to the card slice
against so and then we can just increase
the total quantity in the else part when
we are pushing the items to the array so
we need to increase the total quantity
of the cart so it will be the state
dot total quantity after the items it
will be equals to the plus plus so if i
will now save before that we need to go
to the card.js and then we can just grab
the quantity so the quantity will be
equals to the use selector hooks so the
use selector will grab the state and
then we need to grab the state dot cart
dot total
quantity
so the total quantity will be shown to
the quantity so if i will now save so
now we should see the quantity on to the
screen so if i will not log in so then
you will see now we have the cart of the
zero item so once i will click on the
add to cart so now you will see we have
the one items into the cart and once i
will click on to second product so now
you will see we have two items on to the
cart and once i will click on the add to
cart for the same product so now you
will see we have here in the cart but
now the cart items is only two because
now we have only two products into the
cart
so now we have built the cart item
functionality and now the functionality
which is remaining is now we need to
show the cart items here so then you can
also see we have the total here also as
the 100 but now we will fix that later
so then first we need to build the card
functionality that how we can see the
cart now we are in the cart items.js so
it will show us the single cart item
which is id equals to the one the price
equals to the 2500 and it is equal to
the macbook so it is just showing on to
the single card so now we need to fix
that so we can just grab here the state
from to the redux so it will be the cost
so to the cart items
and it will be equals to the use
selector hook from the react redux and
then we grab the state and then look at
the state
dot cart
dot items list
so now we have the list of all of the
items into that and now we can just grab
here as the state so then instead of the
single li items so we can just comment
it out or we can just remove that so we
can just grab the cart items which we
have about the map
and it will map every single object into
this array so it will be the first item
it will be the item
and then it will contain here the
cart item
which is a single cart item so we have
to just send here the props to the cart
item so the id will be equal to the item
which we have dot id and then it will be
having the the second prop equals to the
price so it the price will be the item
dot price we have and then we have to
send here the total
equals to the item
dot total price
and then we need to send here the name
also
the name will be equals to the item
dot name so now all of the things which
we want to do now we have done that and
then we can just wrap this inside the li
component also so we need to wrap inside
the li so the li will be there so for
the every list item the cart item will
be then shown to that so it will contain
the ally there then we can just close
this and then we can just wrap it inside
the ally so now you will see we have the
ally and then we can provide the key to
this ally because we are now just
rendering the list and so that and each
list should contain a key prop so the
key prop can contain the item dot id
inside that so if i will now save so
then you will see now we should see the
items but now
we are not seeing any items onto the
screen because we need to just render
these cart items into that so we need to
go to the layout and then we need to
just grab here the cart items which we
have so the card icons will be there
after the products so if i will now save
and the cart item will be then imported
here then you will see now we have the
two items into the card and once i will
click on the delete root also so then
you will see it is also there into the
card so now we have the card and now we
need the functionality that once i will
click on the cart icon here so then only
it should show me the card and once i
will click on it again so then you will
see the card should be removed so we
need that functionality and for that we
have also built that functionality in
that
in the card slice.js that set show card
will be equals to the true so we need to
go to the cart item
we need to go to the cart and then you
will see we have the essay so we should
have the on click prop into the s3 and
then it will be the show card
go cart function would be there and then
just we can show the card from this
function so it will just dispatch an
action so cons dispatch
will be equal to the use dispatch
and then we can just add here the
function of the show card as he counts
show card will be equal to the function
and then we can just enter an action so
with the dispatch it will be the cart
actions
dot it will be the set show card so the
set show card will be there and then if
i will now just save
so then you will see that chat show card
will be shown but now we need to also go
to the layout also and then we need to
grab the set show card so for that we
need to go and then we need to get here
this actual card as the show card
and it will be equals to the use
selector hook
and then it will grab the state and then
it will grab the state dot cart
dot show card
so the show card will be there and then
we need to only render this cart items
when the show card will be equals to the
true so when the show card will be close
to the true and then only we need to
render the card i time so if i would now
save and if i will now just refresh the
page once again to clear the cache and
all and once i will click on the login
so then you will see the cart items
equals to the zero once i will click on
the add to cart so now you will see the
card items has the two items also that
and once i will click on it so now you
will see we have the cart items here and
now once i will click on it again so
then you will see the card will not be
shown here because now in the card
slice.js we are just only giving the
value as the true and instead of this
true we should give the value as the
state
dot show card and it will be the
opposite value of the state dot show
card so if i will now save so now you
will see once i will login and add to
cart here at two card here also so now
we have the two items so once i will
click on the card so then you will see
we have the cart here on to the screen
and once i will click on the cart again
so then you will see the card will be
gone so now we have built the
functionality of the cart and now if i
will now click on the card so then you
will see now we have the two buttons
here also
to just remove the item from the cart to
just decrease the quantity and to
increase the quantity so then we can
also fix that so then you will see the
quantity is now the we cannot see the
quantity into that so we have to see the
quantity also so we need to go to the
cart item
cut items.js and then we need to render
and then we need to see how many items
we are having here so then you will see
we have the name
the price the quantity the total
and then we have here all of the things
like that we need to go to the cart
items and then we need to send one more
prop as the quantity which we have
missed so the quantity will be equals to
the item
dot quantity
so if i would now save so then we should
see the quantity and so now you will see
the quantity is one and one to the item
so if i will now click on this again so
then you will see the macbook has the
quantity of three and the lenovo yoga is
one so if i will click on the add to
cart again so then you will see the
quantity is two and the total price is
also equals to the 50 because 25 25 is
also 50
and now we need to work on the on these
two buttons here so then we need to go
to the cart item
and then now you will see we have the
two buttons here onto the cart item so
we can just grab here the on click state
of the button and then we can just
increment
cart
item
and then we can just create the function
for the increment also and for the
decrement also we need to create a
onclick
which will be equal to decrement
card items
and then we need to just create the
functions at the const
increment function will be equals to
there and then this will it will be
having a const
as a decrement
cut items will be equal to the function
and then it will be having the function
again so now you will see now we have
the two functions here
but now we need to build the
functionality also into the card slice
for the remove items from the cart and
for that we need to go to the card slice
and then we need to just work on the
remove items from the cart and now to
work on this functionality now we have
one thing that now we only need the id
to just remove so for that we need to
get this id
so first it will grab the state and then
it will grab the action
so then we can just grab the id from the
payload so it will be the const id of
the product will be equals to the action
dot payload so we will send the id in
the payload and then we can just check
if we have the existing item into the
state so for that we can just check the
existing item
will be equals to the state dot items
list
dot it will be the find
so we will find the item if we have the
item already available on to the state
and then we can just decrease the
quantity so if we have the item as the
item dot id
is equal equals to the id
so it will check if the id is there and
then it will just return here the value
so we can check if the existing item
dot quantity will be
equal equals to the one
so if the quantity is now equals to only
one so we can just remove the items from
the quantity and to remove that we can
just create a new state at the state dot
item list
will be equals to the state
dot item list
so we need to remove from the array and
for that we will use the filter here
for the state dot item list
dot filter so we will just filter this
array of the list so item will be there
as the parameter so we can just filter
as if we only want the items
which have the id item dot id will not
be equals to this id so we want only
these items onto this item list so it
will just filter the array and it will
be shown to the user
so if i will now just save
here from that so then you will see now
we have the quantity equals to the 1 or
else if the quantity is now greater than
the 1 on to this fine method if the
quantity is greater in the existing item
so we can just decrease the quantity
like the existing item dot quantity
will be equals to the minus minus so the
quantity will be decreased
and then we can just decrease the total
price also like the existing item
so total price
will be uh total price will be equals to
the like minus
equals to the
existing item
dot price
so then now we can see the functionality
here right so if i will now save so now
we should see the functionality onto
that and then we need to go to the cart
item dot js which we have here the
single card item
and then we can just grab here some
functions like first we will grab the
dispatch on the const dispatch
now we will dispatch the action from the
use dispatch
and then just we can create a dispatch
functionality onto the increments so the
dispatch we will just increment again as
the auth actions like the cart
actions it will be dot
add to cart and the add to cart will be
there as the same as we did in the
product.js
so it will have the name id and the
price again
it will be having a name
id and the price which we are also
getting into that and then we can just
dispatch the section so if i will now
save and if i will now just go to the
chrome if i will not log in so then you
will see i will now click on the add to
cart
now we have one items into the cart and
now if i will now increment that
quantity so then you will see now we
have the five quantity and once i will
click click on the plus increment again
so then you will see now there is an
error i think onto the screen so we have
to fix that error
so then you will see for the minus icon
we are now sending the increment so for
that we need to send the decrement and
for the increment we need to send the
increment
so it is just change so if i will now
just save
and if i will refresh the page again
to see if there would be any change so
then you will see once i will add to
cart
i have added three to four items here so
then you will see we have the four items
of the 25 dollars
once i will click on the increment so
then you will see the quantity is now
incrementing and the total price is also
incrementing over there
so if i will now click on the lenovo
yoga also if i will click on the
increment so then you will see the
quantity is incrementing and once the
quantity and now we need to work on the
decrement also and for the decrement we
need to grab here the dispatch the card
actions
so the card actions will be there and
dot remove the card and then we need to
remove the card from only the id so if i
will now save and if i will now just
click on the remove so then you will see
the quantity is now decrementing and
once it will reach the one and if i will
now just decrement again so then you
will see it is now decremented from the
cart also it is now removed from the
cart also so now we have seen all of the
functionalities are now working again so
then now you will see once i will click
on the add to cart add to cart again so
then you will see the cart as the two
items one table click on to remove this
i will remove this so then you will see
now all of the things are not removed
from the cart so now we have built the
cart functionality also into that
and now we have one more error because
now once i will click on the add to cart
so then you will see now we have the
cart items at the four because now we
have removed that items and now you will
see the cart items are only incrementing
but not decrementing so if i will now
just decrement this so now you will see
the cart items are not decrementing so
for that we need to go to the card slice
and then in the card slice so if we have
the existing item dot quantity
equal equals to one so if we have only
the single quantity then we can also
just
uh decrement the total quantity from the
cart so it will be the state dot total
quantity minus minus if i will now log
in once again
i will now click on the add to cart now
we have the three items onto the cart so
once i will show the card so then you
will see now we have the macbook of the
three units once i will decrement so
then you will see now we have the one
unit remaining and now you will see now
we have the two items once i will
decrement it also now we have the one
item if i will now decrement this now we
have the one item only on to the cart
and now you will see all of the things
are now working out fine and now we only
need to fix this total price also and
the logout functionality so for the
total we need to go to the layout
which we have that layout.js and then we
can just create here the total because
total is the static value
so we can just give this value as the
zero
so we can grab all of the items from the
state from the uh redux state and then
we can just increment the total from to
their price so it will the cost items
list
will be equals to the use selector
and the use selector will grab the state
and the state
dot cart
dot items list
so then it will be having the item list
so we can just create here the items
list
dot for each loop
so the for each loop will contain a
parameter as the item and then it will
contain the parameter then inside that
also
so it will just increment that so the
item so the total will be plus equals to
the item
dot it will be the
total price
so the total price will be there of the
items
with their quantity also total will be
plus equals to the item dot total price
so if i will now save and if i will now
just go to the screen once again so now
we should see the total price so now we
can see the card as the zero items and
once i will click on the add to cart so
then you will see now we have the total
of the 25 dollars once i will increment
it so then you will see now we have the
hundred dollars and the four items here
and once i will click any other item
like hp pavilion so now you will see we
have the 25 dollars again so now you
will see all of the things are now
working except the log out so for the
logout we can create another button
after the cart items after for the
logout functionality
so now for the logout functionality we
need to go to the header component and
then we can just create a new li after
the cart so it will be the li and it
will contain the button
and the button will contain as the
logout so then we can just tile the
button as well so we can just style as
the class name will be equals to like
the button
logout button
so then you will see we need to style
the class name all source and then we
need to go to the css
and then we need to style the css
so the layout.css and then we can give
as the layout button
and then just we can provide as the
class name
and then we can just provide the
padding of the 10 pixels and then we can
provide here another thing like uh we
can provide here
as the uh background
so the background will be orange
and then if i will now provided one
thing as the border will be equals to
the none
so now we have here and then if i will
not provide as the logout button as the
hover
so the hover will contain the background
so the background will contain as the
rgb zero six and the five nine so if i
will now save so then now we should see
there will be a button and then you will
see we have here the logout
functionality so once i will click on
the logout
so we should be logged out so we need to
go to the header.js and then we can just
provide the functionality
of the own click
so the own click is there and then we
can just provide as a logout function
logout handler
and then we can just provide it as the
function like now we can just create the
function as he const
log out handler
and then we can just create a dispatch
functionality also so it will the const
dispatch
will be equal to the use dispatch once
again
and then we can just dispatch here an
action of the logout of the odd slice so
it will be the dispatch and then auth
actions which we have dot logout so it
will be just logged out so once i will
click on the logout so it will be logged
out so if i will now save so now you
will see we have here the logout button
so once i will click on the logout so
now you will see the screen is now
logged out and once i will click on the
login so now you will see we still have
the cart of the two items onto the state
so we have covered the functionality of
all of the things
so now we have built the logic and now
the only thing which is remaining is
sending the shopping cart data to the
back end but we know that the reducers
must be pure and side effect free and
the synchronous functions always so if
we have an http call which is an
asynchronous task so such type of code
must not go through the reducer
functions so we can't send an http
request inside the reducers we can't use
any fetch and descend request from one
reducer function to fetch the request
and we must never do something like this
so i strongly suggest you that don't run
the asynchronous code here so instead we
have the two options to put the
asynchronous code
the first option is inside the
components with using the use if i took
like we can do inside the product.js
whenever we are sending the data to the
cart so we can add here use if i took to
send the data to the cart and the second
option is to create an action creator
which would allow us to run the
asynchronous code so these are the two
main options here and in this course we
will perform both the operation
so now we will go with the first
approach and for the backend code i will
use a firebase
so firebase is a great tool which don't
require any backend code so we can go to
the firebase
and we can create our account here with
the firebase so you can go with the
second link and then we can go to the go
to console so it will just log in and it
will just allow us to create a new
firebase project so we can create a new
project with the button at the create a
project and then we can add a project
name like i will add the
http
and then i will just accept the terms
and conditions and i will just click on
the continue button and then we can just
click on the continue again to enable
the google analytics and then the server
would be same i don't want to change so
we can click on the create project it
will create a project within one minute
and then you can use the firebase
so now the firebase setup is now
completed so now we have to go to the
product component but now if we directly
add a product from the product item
component so it would be wrong because
if we only send the data to the backend
and it doesn't have any logic and the
reducer functions will be of no use then
because if we send any single product
two times into the backend then the back
end doesn't know that this product is
already being part of the cart so for
all the logic we have in the producer so
if the product is already part of the
cart so then we can update the quantity
so this logic won't run on the firebase
or you have to add another functions in
the firebase to do that you could add a
server-side code to it and then the
functions
so if you want to try the another
solution so the another solution is
we have to let the redux manage the
state on its sound and then after the
redux manages the state then we can
update the server on the back end with
the updated state from the redux so we
can first do the work on the front end
and let the redux update the store and
second after that we will send the
request to the server so we can do it in
the main app.js file because now then in
that file we can grab the state from the
redux by creating a new selector hook so
cost
the whole card state will be equals to
the card and it will because of the use
selector
and then it will be having a state
inside it and then we have to grab the
state dot cart so we can grab the card
state from here and then we can just
send an http request from there
so we can add the use effect after this
console.log so we have to remove this
cart items because it is of no use then
then we can use a use effect
so the use effect will then be imported
from the uh
react and then it will be having a
callback function inside it and then it
will contain an array of dependencies so
then we will add the dependency later so
then we can use a inbuilt javascript
function which is the fetch to send the
request to the database so then to add
here the url so we have to click on the
continue after the project is completed
and then we need to go inside the
project and then we need to go and then
we need to click the build and then the
real time database so we will use the
real-time database from the firebase to
use this and then we can go
and then we can grab the url of the
real-time database
so we can click on the create database
here
and then it will ask you some options so
you can just click on the next again and
then
start in locked mode so you can just
enable again and then you will see the
url will be here within a moment so now
you can see we have a url here of the
redux so it is the rest api url which we
will be having here so this is the url
layer and then we can just go to the
rows to add the data to inside it
so we have to go to the rules and we
have to modify this rules so read we
have to enable it to the true and then
to the right we have to get it to the
true so we have to change the read and
write data here to from false to the
true and then we have to publish and
then the new rules will be published
within a moment so you can just
click the dismiss here and then we have
to go to the data and then we have to
grab this url
so we have to grab this url just copy
the url and then in the fetch you have
to paste this url and then after this
slash.firebase.com now we have to create
here the collection so the collection
name will be can be the card items
dot json
so dot json should be always there now
because it help us to add the collection
there and then we can just fetch and
then we can just specify here some
object method of this fetch url will be
the put so we have to send here the put
data so whenever the data will be
modified into this state so we can just
add here the put request so the so the
firebase could also access that modified
state from the redux
so we can just add there after the
method we have to add the body of the
request
so we have to specify the body and it
will contain a json object like the json
it will be having a stringify so it will
just stringify all the card data into it
and then the request will be sent to the
back end and then we need to specify the
cart into this array of dependencies so
that the if the cart value will be
changed in the redux so the use effect
will notified and then we can just run
the fetch function and then it will
update the data there so if i will now
save
and if i will now go to the redux app if
i will now just refresh and then we will
start from the scratch so now we are
logged in so if i will add any product
to the database like macbook if i will
click on the add to cart so now you will
see the cart has one items and if i will
add the lenovo yoga also
now the card has two items so if i will
now go to the real time database now you
will see
we have a collection of the cart item so
if you will expand
now you will see we have the total
quantity of 2 and the show card which is
equals to the true and then we have the
items list inside that so then you will
see we have a array so the zero index of
the array have the macbook which is of
the price and the quantity is one and
the total price is 25 and then we have
the first array which contains a lenovo
yoga laptop
the price is 25 and the total price is
also 25 so now you will see the put
request is working and now the firebase
is now able to access the latest state
snapshot from the redux that we have so
whenever the data will be changed inside
the redux slices redux reduces so the
use effect will be modified and it will
send the request to the redux by the
http
so now i'm sending this request but i'm
not doing anything with the response
which i will get from this server so i'm
not handling any type of potential
errors that could occur during this
fetch function so we will create a
notification component so that we should
be notified about the errors and the
states of the redux that how and when
the redux state is updated
so first we have to convert this fetch
function into the asynchronous function
so we have to declare the function here
inside the use effect at the send
request
and it will be equals to the function
and it will be the async function and
the arrow function
and then we have to just create a new
variable here as the cons response which
we will get
by doing the await and then by updating
the state from the redux
to the firebase so now we will just wait
for the fetch function to run and then
we will create a new data variable so
whenever the response will be successful
we will just convert the response to the
json format
whenever we will get from the server and
this will also be the await so that it
should take some time and then now
whenever we will reach the data here so
it means that now the response is
successful and now we should see the
data in the back end so now we will call
the send request function so we have to
create a notification component and then
we have to create the slice and the new
state for the notification to handle all
of the state from the ui
so now we have to go and we have to
create the notification component with
notification
dot js
and i will add a basic letter pair for
that so now we have to go to the
material ui so you have to go
and type the material ui into the
browser and you have to install the
material ui library from the react
so you have to copy this command and you
have to paste this command inside the
terminal and you have to install this
material ui so we have to wait till it
completes the installation and then we
will continue
and now the material ui is installed and
now we have to import something from the
material ui which will be the alert so
we will show the alert box from the
material ui and it will be
imported from the
mui material instead of the notification
then we have to add here the alert
to the alert and then it will contain
two props at the severity and it will be
equals to the dynamic severity so we
will get the two props here as we type
and then the message we want to show
and then it will contain a message here
also inside the alert it will be the
message
so now we have created the alert box so
now we have to go to the app.js and then
we have to add here the notification so
then it will be imported and then we can
just provide the type prop and the type
will be equal to the success this is
aesthetic and then it will be converted
to the dynamic into the notification
and then we can add here the message
will be equals to like it will be the
like this is dummy message
if i will now save and if i will now
just get the notification also so it
will be imported so if i will now save
so then we should see the notification
onto the screen so now it is compiled so
if i will now go to the react redux app
so then you will see there is a dummy
message onto the screen which is a
notification component so now you will
see we have a notification and now we
need to handle all of the states of the
notification into the redux so we will
create a new slice into the redux so it
will be the ui slice
so it will be the ui
slice dot js
and then we have to create a new slice
for the ui so the cost
ui slice
will be equals to the create slice
and the create slice will then be
imported from the redux so first we will
provide here the name
so the name will be equals to the ui
slice
and then we will just create the initial
state so initial state will be having an
object with the notification inside that
and the notification by default value
will be equals to the null and then we
will just create here the reducer
functions
to add some data inside it so first it
will contain a function at the show
notification so the show notification
function will contain the state as the
parameters and then it will contain the
action so then we will just add the
action dot payload property into the
notification object and then it will
show the notification into the app.js
so then we will add here as a state dot
notification will be equals to an object
and then it will contain the message
will be equal to the action
dot payload dot message
and then it will be having a new thing
as the type
so the type will be equals to the action
dot payload dot type
and then it will have an open prop so
whenever we need to open the
notification so we have to add here the
open so the action
dot payload dot open so now these three
things will be now there into the shown
notification so whenever this using will
be there so the notification will be
shown so then we need to just export
here the actions of the ui slice goes to
the ui slice dot actions and then we
need to just export this variable
and then we need to just export the ui
slice now as the default export so it
will export default
as the ui slice
so now we need to go to the index
dot js into the store and then we need
to add the ui slice also as the ui and
it will contain the ui slice
dot it will contain the reducer so now
we have given the ui slice on to the
redux store so then we can use the store
also
and now we need to go to the app.js to
handle the state so now we have to use
the dispatch into the app.function so
whenever we will reach the send request
function we will send the rig state
as
sending request
and then we will just go whenever we
will get the data so then we will send a
new state at the send state to
notification as now the request is
successful and whenever we get an error
from the request so we will use the send
request dot catch it will have the error
inside that so we will just add a new
dispatch function inside that and here
we will just dispatch a new action
as now we have now error so send state
as error so now we have the three
dispatch functions will be here so now
we have to use the dispatch function so
we have to create accounts dispatch
will be equal to the use dispatch and it
will be from the react redux so it will
be imported from the react redux as you
can see and then we can just dispatch
here an action so whenever we are
sending the request
so it should be the dispatch and then we
have to get the ui actions which we have
imported so it will also be imported
from the store and the ui slice
to the ui actions dot show notification
and now it will contain an object so
first property will be equal to the open
so we have to set the open property now
equals to the true and then we have to
set a message so the message property
will be equals to now as the
it will contain like the sending
request
and now it will contain a type
of the alert box in the material ui
which needs to be specified which will
be equals to the warning and the type
should be of the same spelling here
because it is used in the material ui at
the static strings
so then we are now dispatching the
actions at the show notification so type
equals to the warning so whenever the
response will be converted to the json
so then we have to use another dispatch
and then we have to get here open true
and then we have to set the message at
the send request to database
successfully and then the type will be
equals to a success
from the material ui and then whenever
we will get an error from this end
request function so we will catch an
error and then we will throw a new
dispatch function here again so the
dispatch will be having open truth the
message will be
the sending request failed
and the type will be equal to the error
so if i will now save so now we should
see all of the things here but now we
need to convert all of the type equal to
success and the message to the
dynamically so then we need to just add
here the useless hook so const and it
will be having a notification will be
equal to the use selector so we will get
the notification from the state from the
state and then the state dot ui
dot notification and then we will send
all of the data dynamically through this
object so it will be having a type
will be equals to like we have to get
here the type as the notification
dot type and then in the message we have
to get here as the
instead of this we will get the
notification dot message
and the open prop should always be in
the notification state so we have to go
to the notification and then we have to
get if the state is now open and then
only we need to show the notification so
for that we will create a use selector
hook as the const
open
will be equals to the use selector hook
again
and it will be having a state as the
parameter of the callback so we will get
the state dot ui
dot notification
so we can only get the notification here
because we have to get the notification
so sometimes it would be undefined so we
have to get we have to check all of the
errors so it will be the notification
and it will become your dui down
notification and then we will check
whenever we will have the notification
inside that
so it will be having that so whenever
the notification dot open is true
and then only we need to show the alert
and then we will add one more thing to
the alert so it will on close so
whenever it will be closed so then it
should be having a function where the
handle close
so then we will get the handle close
so it will be having a cost handle close
will be equal to the function so the
handle close will now contain a new
dispatch again so we have to get the
dispatch from the useless launched
dispatch
will be equals to the use dispatch from
the react redux and then we need to
dispatch an action whenever we are now
closing the alert box and then we need
to set the open to the false we need to
set the open property of the ui slice to
the false so that and it should not
overlap the content of the state so we
have to get here as the open so it is
showing as the open so we have to fix
this also so then we need to go to the
uh notification again
and then we need to satire the ui
actions again ui actions will be equals
to the ui actions the show notification
we only need to set here the prop the
open which will equals to the false
so if i will now save and if i will now
just go to the app.js now to handle the
things so now we need to go to the
app.js and then we have to check so when
we would be having the notification into
the state and then only we have to show
the notification so if i will now save
so now you will see alert is showing
initially because the use effect is
running on the first render as well so
to fix it we have to just stop it from
the rending for the first time and then
we can create a variable before the
component function to check if it is the
first render and then we need to stop
the use effect from rendering so we can
create a variable is first render
will be equals to like the true
and then we can just go to the use
effect and then we can just check a
condition like if it is the first render
we need to just set the is first render
will be equal to now the fall so now the
first standard is false and then we need
to just add the return
whenever it will be the first render so
it will be returned so if i will now
save now you will see whenever i will
now refresh so now you will see it will
not show initially and once i will click
on the login and now you will see the
application is now working fine so now
you will see now the redux state has
empty items so now you will see the
array is empty
so we have to check if the array is
still there or not so then you will see
now we don't have anything inside that
so if i will not just add something to
the cart add to cart so then you will
see the sending request is there and
then you will see that now the request
is sent successfully to the database and
once i will go to the database so then
you will see the cart items is there and
we have the quantity equals to the one
and we have the first item in the array
and if i will now click on one more item
to there so add two cards so then you
will see sending request the
notification is showing and then you
will see the notification is now
completed send request to database
successfully so then you will see now we
have total quantity 2 and now we have
one more error in the database so now we
have completed functionality of the
notification icons
and now we are missing one thing and now
we need to fetch the data from the
firebase but before we start fetching
the data let's have a look at the
alternative solution that we have
discussed which is the other option
which is the action creator
so now even the dispatch is an action
creator it sends an action now we can
write our own action creators as well
which is known as the thunks so what is
a thunk but a thung is a function that
delays an action until later and we can
write an action creator as thunk which
does not immediately returns then action
object but which returns another
function which returns the action so we
can run the other code before we
dispatch the actual action object and it
is very common battery in the redux
let's now we will see how we can achieve
that so we need to go to the card slice
and then we need to create here after
the reducers now we need to create a the
function like the send
card data
now the send card data will be equals to
the function which will receive a
parameter sd card now we will see from
where we will call that but now we will
just stick to the implementation of this
send card data and then it returns
another function as we have discussed
which contains the dispatch as the
parameters
and then we will just dispatch another
action so this will return another
function inside that and now we have to
go to the app.js which we have and now
if i will now just grab
this action objects like this will be
equal to dispatch
so i will now dispatch this action if i
will not cut from here and if i will now
go to the card slice and then if i will
now just add the dispatch here and then
you will see we have a ui action then we
have to grab the ui action and we have
to import that
and now you will see now we are
dispatching first the notification icon
which is the sending request and then we
will go to the app.js once again and if
i will now just catch the send request
function also
from there so we have to get this
function i will grab this function from
there to dispatch so i will now just
copy this function and if i will now
just cut this here and if i will now
just paste through the card slice and
now we need to call the send request
function with the try catch block like
we will try and then it will be the
await and then it will be the send
request
so it will the send request
so now we are now using the await so and
it can be a async function also so now
it is now await
and now after this we will now adhere
the catch block which will catch an
error and then instead of catching the
error now we will go to the app.js once
again and i will now grab the ui actions
dot show notification also if we have
seen an error so i will now grab this
and if i will now just go to the card
slice once again i will now dispatch the
action with the error from here so now
we have implemented the send card data
function to there and now we will see
from where we will call and now we need
to export this data export this function
this end card data and now we need to go
to the app.js and i will now just clean
everything from there
from this end request and now we need to
call here this and
cart request data send card data here
and then it will be having a cart as the
parameter and then we need to provide
the card parameter there and now we are
now sending the data and now this is a
thunk and the action creator so we need
to dispatch it so we need to add it
inside the dispatch so it will dispatch
and now we are now dispatching the send
card data function
and we are now adding the card inside
that so now this will be the function
which will be using the dispatch and the
send card data so if i will now save and
if i will now just go to the chrome once
again to check if everything is working
fine so now we are in the react redux
app if i will now just refresh now you
will see now we have a login screen i
will now click on the login and if i
will now click on the add to cart so now
you will see we have a sending request
notification
and then it should be successful so now
you will see the notification is
successful and if i will not just go to
the firebase you can see we have the
item list and we have one data into the
item list so now you will see everything
is fine now and if i will now click on
the add to cart once again so then you
will see the request should be
successful and then we should go to the
firebase and now you will see we have a
one more item into the list and now what
we are doing here now we are sending
here the dispatch like this and we are
adding a send card data which is a thunk
function in the redux and we are adding
a cart as the parameter which we will
receive from the card from the use
selector and now the redux will go ahead
and it will dispatch this function for
us and all other functions will be
dispatched inside the send card data
function now we have so many functions
inside that and the http request will
also be performed and this pattern may
look complicated but it is a supported
pattern by the redux and it is known as
the thunk pattern and why we had this
because this is an alternative that we
should have the logics and all of the
data and the action creators inside the
redux only and the most important you
can stuck to the previous pattern as
well if you found it good but it's a
good idea to keep your components clean
and just only have all of the logics and
the side effect logics inside the redux
and now you have seen about the thunk
function so now let's build another
action creator to fetch the data from
the firebase to fetch all of the card
data from the firebase so now if i will
now go to the card slice one second if i
will now just grab this so now you will
see we have a card slice and now we have
a card slice send card data function
which is now exporting so now
to make this file cleaner so i will now
cut this file and if i will now create
another file as the cart
dash actions
dot js i will now add this function into
this cart so then you will see now i
have pasted this function into this car
so then we need to import the ui actions
also to make that file cleaner so now we
have seen this function and now we need
to create a one more function to fetch
the request from the firebase and to
fetch all of the data from the firebase
and to just update to the front end and
for that we need to create another
action creator thunk so it will be like
the export it will be exported and the
cost at the fetch data
which will be equals to like the
function and then we need to add here
the function inside that and then we
need to return here another function
inside that as we have did in the
previous video also it will require
dispatch and it will be equals to
an arrow function once again and this
will also be the async function because
we are not fetching the request from the
firebase so now we can create a new
request to fetch the data and for that i
will create a function
as the fetch handler inside that and it
will be the function to fetch the data
inside that so it will be the
asynchronous function
and then we will create a one more
variable with the function to fetch the
request like response and response we
will get from the firebase from the
await and then we have to fetch the
request so there is a function with the
fetch and then we need to add the url
inside that so we can grab this url from
the http till the card.json and this
will be a get request so we don't need
to specify the method here inside that
and then we can just get the data
at the cost data will be equal to the
await so once the request will be
successful so we will get the response
and then we will convert the response to
the json so now we have the data inside
the data variable and then we will
return the data
so the data will be now returned and now
we need to call this function so we can
call this function inside the try catch
block because this is a promise so we
can just get the cons car data
will be equals to await and then the
fetch handler
so the fetch handler function will
return the data and now we have the data
and now we need to create a one more
reducer function in the card slice to
get the data and to update the data onto
the redux and the front end also so for
that i will add another function here
as like the in the reducers i will add a
one more function as the replace data
replace data so the data on the front
end because now initially the data would
be empty so we can just replace the
empty data with the data we have in the
firebase to update the content of the
cart
so it will be close to the state so
total quantity
will be equals to
will be equals to
the action
dot payload which we will receive so it
will retrieve two properties and the
state and the action so the action dot
payload will be there and then action
dot payload total price it will be
updated from the firebase and then it
will get the item list also item list
will be equals to the action dot payload
dot item list that we have
and now they replace card data now we
need to call this function replace data
inside that so whenever we will send the
request to data now we will dispatch one
more function
as the cart actions so we need to import
cart actions
dot replace data
so the replace data would be there and
then we need to replace the data which
is the cash data which we have so it
will replace all of the data with the
card data which we have in the firebase
and it will reflect on to the front end
and now we will add a cache block here
also to cache an error if we have an
error so if so it will show as an error
and then we can just add here one more
thing
so we can add here a new dispatch action
as the ui dot error so it should show us
the error onto the screen so inside the
catch block
we will add this error and this will
actually sending request it should show
us the error
and now the thing is now we have created
the function and now here we want to
call it and to call this function we
need to go to the app.js that we have
and in the app.js we need to create
another use effect to call this and this
use effect will run initially as well as
we have stopped the another use effect
to don't run initially and then it will
be having a fetch data so we have to get
here the dispatch function we have to
dispatch here
so whenever we will get the request
whenever the application will be open so
we need to dispatch an action and then
we need to fetch the data
from the fireplace so the fetch data
will be imported from the actions from
the cart action so then you will see
cart actions it will be imported and
then
it should show us all of the things and
then now you will see in the area of
dependencies we can add a dispatch
function where we have and now we will
see now we have moved the send card data
into the cart actions as well so i will
now remove from here and i will now just
import the send card data from the cart
actions as well so now you will see the
send card data and the all of the things
are imported from the correct place so
if i will now save and if i will now go
to the screen so it should not show us
an error so now you will see it is
showing us an error it is not an error
but this is a initial request so
whenever we are opening the application
it is sending the request to the
database
and when the first render is complete
then the second render is then
completing so then you will see the
sending card data is now sending again
and again the data to the user to the
firebase
so whenever this request will be
successful whenever the application will
be opened so this request will be run
and after that then the second render
will be true and then we will send this
request there so we have to stop this
because this is a problem and now to
solve this now we need to go to the card
slice and then now we can add a new
parameter here as the changed so it will
be equals to the changed
will be equals to the false and then the
change will be equals to the false so we
can check whenever the data will be
changed and then only we need to run
this render and then only we need to
send the request to the database so then
you will see once we will go to the add
to cart so then you will see the state
so the state will now be changed so when
it will reach the add two cards the
stage will be changed to true and then
once it will reach to the remove to card
as well so the state will be changed as
well from here also stage dot end equals
to the true so now we need to check it
inside the app.js also so once we will
go to the app.js and then we can check
we have to send card data only when we
have a condition so we can check our
condition via if statement like if we
have the cart and then if the card dot
change
equals to the true and then only we need
to send this dispatch request so if i
will not copy and if i will not just
paste inside that so if i will now say
with all of that and i should see the
server should be okay so then you will
see now we have the application now
initially we don't see any request and
once i will click on the login and now
you will see we have the cart of the one
items as well into the firebase also
into here also and now this means that
now we have completed the full redux
functionality into this application and
now we are also matching the card data
from the firebase as well and once i
will click on the add to cart now you
will see the sending request to database
successfully we can close this
notification and i will add one more
item now you will see now we have three
items inside that and once i will go to
the redux firebase now you will see we
have the all of the items in the item
list we have the quantity of three and
now we have all of the items inside that
so now we have completed the full redux
course and i hope you have learned a lot
from this course and there can be some
optimizations as well so you can just
move the change property and the show
card property to the ui slice as well
and it should be the assignment for you
so you can do that
so now we have completed two
applications with the redux the first
one is the basic counter application and
the second one is a bigger project with
a shopping cart application so now i
hope you have learned the redux then
what is the redux why we need it and how
can we make use of it in the real world
applications and how can we run
asynchronous tasks with the redux so if
you have any doubts or you are facing
any issues so connect with me and i will
help you out and i have added the source
code also into the description so you
can take help from that also so thanks
for watching and if you learned
something new from me then do me a favor
like this video and please subscribe to
the channel so i can create more videos
like that so thank you have a nice day